if you look at somebody who is
quite a bit different than that george
st pierre
who at least in the way he describes it
he's basically
exceptionally anxious yes and terrified
approaching
a fight and he loves training
and hates fighting and hates fighting so
and
just like you said he made it work for
him
but you he's somebody he speaks very
highly of you he's worked with you
quite a bit in training
and you've studied him you've worked
with him you've coached him
interestingly i've actually coached
george for twice the length of any of
the squad members so
my knowledge of him is far greater than
it is for
really contemporary squads can you speak
to
what makes george st pierre who i think
even though i'm russian
and a little bit partial towards fedor
and the the russians but
i think he is in the four categories you
mentioned
the greatest mixed martial artist of all
time
what makes him so good his approach his
techniques
his mind his approach is certainly part
of it
george started mixed martial arts at a
time when
the sport was in a pretty wild phase
it was illegal to show on most american
tv networks
and um there was talk about it being
banned as a sport
uh and as native canada it was banned
you could only fight on indian
reservations and in canada i believe his
first
fight may have been on an indian
reservation um
so the sport at that stage
was very much in its infancy and
it's probably fair to say that most of
the athletes
involved in the sport came from
a training program that would probably
be described as
unprofessional and and
in the contemporary scene
um george is one of a handful of people
who started
approaching the sport in a truly
professional fashion it was like okay
here's what great athletes in other
sports do i'm going to try to emulate
that
and
his ability to invest in himself
in my own experience for example george
when i first met him was a garbage man
and he would jump on
a bus from montreal to new york
now that's a that's a long bus ride he
would come down on friday afternoon when
he finished
work as a garbage man stay for the
weekend and then late on sunday night he
would jump on a bus
all the way back to montreal and work as
a garbage man
that's an extraordinary commitment for a
young man
to make that's and
george was a blue belt at the time and
so he would come down
and you know we had a very talented room
so
uh he didn't do well in the room when he
first came in he was inexperienced in
jujitsu and uh
the people who went against were
considerably better than hermit jujitsu
so imagine
investing 25 of your weekly income
maybe even more new york's an expensive
town 50 percent
to come down and just get your ass
kicked
month by month yeah that says a lot but
tells you a lot first of all let's talk
about the whole idea of delayed
gratification here i mean um
that's that's the guy who's saying like
this is highly unpleasant but i have a
vision of myself in the future
and i have to go through this extreme
case of delayed gratification to get to
that distant goal
which may never happen and uh
that's that's the level of commitment
and self-belief which is just
extraordinary
um i always laugh when people say you
know george was afraid so he was
mentally weak
like no that's that's a very
very shallow understanding of mental
strength and weakness
um george felt anxiety
but let's understand from the start
there's different kinds of mental
strength
and the most important kind isn't
whether you feel
fear or don't feel fear before you step
into fight the most important form of
mental strength
is discipline and training that's where
most people break
i know dozens of people who are fearless
to fight
but you couldn't get them to come into
the gym for three months in a row and
work on skills
yeah so they're mentally strong one way
they don't feel fear
but they're mentally weak in another
which is to instill them the discipline
which keeps you on a road to progress
over time
that's much tougher than not feeling
fear before you go out to fight
understand also that when george talks
about fear
he's not afraid of his opponent he's
afraid of failure
he's got high standards someone who's
got high standards
can change the world his standards were
very very high
that's what he was afraid of wasn't
afraid of his opponent
and yet it's always been the
misinterpretation he wasn't mentally
weak he was mentally strong as an ox
okay to stay in his training regimen
year after year after year and do so
while he became one of the first stars
in mixed martial arts to actually make
money
and it gets tough to to stay in the
training gym with people who are young
and
hungry and want to punch you in the face
you're coming out of a luxury room
living in finery towards the end of his
career and still training as hard as
ever that's an impressive thing
and always he valued perfection and
you're right that was
the fear was not achieving the
perfection
is there something you've uh observed
about the way he approaches
training that uh
stands out to you or is it simply the
dedication no
it's never just about dedication there's
lots of dedicated people in the world
but most of them are unsuccessful
if you want to be the best in the world
at anything
you have to do out of the many skills of
whatever
industry you're in you have to take at
least
one of those skills and be the best in
the world at it
there's many skills in mixed martial
arts
but george identified one skill
which is the skill of striking to take
downs he calls it shoot boxing
shoot boxing was barely even a
category of skill when george began it
was just the idea that wrestlers
grabbed people and took them down the
same way they did in wrestling and
and um uh you threw some punches before
you did it
okay george
largely pioneered this science
of creating an interface between
striking and takedowns
he did it at a time where
no one else before him had made it into
a system or a science
he did it largely on his own and
i've always said george is the only
athlete that i ever coached who taught
me
more than i taught him and
almost single-handedly he created this
strong sense of shoot boxing as a
science
which enabled him throughout his career
to determine where the fight would take
place
would it be standing or would it be on
the ground and that
more than anything else was the defining
characteristic of his success
um i will always be
immensely impressed by his
accomplishment in that regard he was an
innovator he did things differently this
is
such an important point you can't go out
there in combat sports
and do the same things that everybody
else is doing
and expect to get different results it
life doesn't work that way if you want
to be dominant
you got to find one important part of
the sport and preferably more than one
and be the best in the world at it you
can't be weak at anything
but you can't be strong at everything
either life's not long enough for us to
develop a
truly complete skill set so you've got
to be good at everything
and you've got to be the best at at
least one thing and george was the best
at two in his era he was the best at
striking to take downs and he was the
best at integrating
striking and grappling on the floor
you